WON'T TELL US WHAT IT IS AND
IT'LL GO ON AND ON AND ON.
>> Juan: THIS IS A FOX NEWS
ALERT.
ROBERT MUELLER HAS SUBMITTED HIS
REPORT TO ATTORNEY GENERAL
WILLIAM BARR.
THE SPECIAL COUNSEL HAS BEEN
PROBING ALLEGED RUSSIAN
INTERFERENCE IN 2016 ELECTION
FOR THE PAST 21 MONTHS.
THE MOVE THEY'LL SETTING UP A
POTENTIAL SHOWDOWN OVER HOW MUCH
OF IT WILL BE MADE PUBLIC.
BARR INDICATED HE'LL SEND HIS
OWN SUMMARY OF THE FINDINGS TO
CONGRESS RATHER THAN MUELLER'S
ACTUAL REPORT.
WHILE DEMOCRATS HAVE THREATENED
TO SUBPOENA MUELLER TO TESTIFY
PUBLICLY ABOUT WHAT HE FOUND.
MUELLER'S TEAM HAS EITHER
INDICTED, CONVICTED, OR GOTTEN
GUILTY PLEAS FROM 34 PEOPLE IN
THREE COMPANIES, INCLUDING SIX
FORMER TRUMP ADVISORS AND/OR
ASSOCIATES.
DANA, WE JUST DON'T KNOW WHO'S
BEEN INDICTED, WHO HAS BEEN
EXONERATED, BUT THE PRESIDENT IN
TALKING WITH MARIA BARTOLOTTA
THIS MORNING SAYS PEOPLE WILL
NOT STAND FOR IT IF IT INDICATES
THAT THERE IS SOME WRONGDOING
BECAUSE HE CONTINUES TO SAY IT
WAS A WITCH HUNT.
>> Dana: I WANT TO TAKE A STEP
BACK AND SAY OF COURSE THE MEDIA
COVERS THE ANGLE THAT WAS THEIR
TRUMP COLLUSION, TRUMP
INVOLVEMENT, THAT HAS BEEN WITH
THE MEDIA.
FRANKLY WE'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT
IT.
REMEMBER, THE GENESIS OF THE
REPORT, IT WASN'T ABOUT 80 BAD
DEALINGS ON BEHALF OF THE
TRUMPS.
IT WAS ABOUT THE RUSSIANS AND
ATTEMPTED INFLUENCE AND
BASICALLY TRYING TO DISRUPT OUR
ELECTION.
AND WE KNOW FROM OUR
INTELLIGENCE AGENCIES AND THE
AND THE DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND
SECURITY'S, THOSE EFFORTS BY THE
RUSSIANS CONTINUE TO THIS DAY
AND WE ARE HEADING INTO AN
IMPORTANT ELECTION.
SETTING ASIDE HOW RUSSIA TRY TO
GET INVOLVED WITH THESE PEOPLE
IF THERE WAS INVOLVEMENT,
ET CETERA, I THINK THIS REPORT
COULD BE QUITE INSTRUCTIVE ABOUT
WHAT WE NEED TO DO TO PROTECT
OUR ELECTIONS GOING FORWARD.
LIKE HOW BIG THAT THREAT IS.
I THINK THAT'S EVEN MORE
IMPORTANT THAN ANYTHING ELSE.
BECAUSE WE, OBVIOUSLY OUR
COUNTRY IS SURVIVING.
WE AREN'T IN A CONFRONTATIONAL
CRISIS.
GOING FORWARD, IF PEOPLE DO NOT
TRUST THE OUTCOME OF AN
ELECTION, IT ALL COULD FALL
APART.
>> Juan: THAT'S A GREAT POINT.
>> Dana: THANK YOU.
>> Juan: JOHN ROBERTS WITH US
NOW.
>> EXPECTING SHORTLY A STATEMENT
FROM THE PRESIDENT'S LAWYERS,
JAY SEKULOW AND RUDY GIULIANI.
EARLIER THIS MORNING, THE
PRESIDENT SAID HE HAD NO IDEA,
HE WAS IN THE DARK LIKE THE REST
OF US WITH THE REPORT MIGHT COME
OUT, BUT HE WAS DOING HIS BEST
WHEN LEAVING FROM MAR-A-LAGO
THIS MORNING TO DISCREDIT THE
MUELLER INVESTIGATION YET AGAIN
AND WHATEVER THE CONTENTS OF THE
REPORT MIGHT BE, SAYING THAT
THERE WAS NO COLLUSION AND THERE
WAS A WITCH HUNT.
WE DO NOT KNOW WHAT THE PROCESS
IS GOING TO BE, THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL'S OFFICE HAS DELIVERED
IT AS IT HAS TO BY STATUTE TO
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL.
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL WILL NOW
REVIEW WITH AND DECIDE WHAT WILL
BE SENT TO CONGRESS, IF ANYTHING
WILL BE SENT TO CONGRESS, WHAT
MIGHT BE MADE PUBLIC, IF
ANYTHING WILL BE MADE PUBLIC.
BARR SAID DURING HIS
CONFIRMATION HEARINGS HE'LL DO
HIS BEST TO MAKE AS MUCH OF THE
REPORT PUBLIC IS POSSIBLY COULD.
THERE'S ALSO A POTENTIAL HERE
FOR THE WHITE HOUSE TO GET
INVOLVED.
IF THERE IS NO MATERIAL IN THE
REPORT THAT IS SUBJECT TO
EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE, THE
WHITE HOUSE MIGHT NOT ASK TO SEE
IT.
BUT IF THERE IS MATERIAL
CONTAINED IN THE REPORT THAT IS
SUBJECT TO EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE,
THAT'S THE WHITE HOUSE COUNSEL
HERE AT
1600 PENNSYLVANIA AVENUE, THEY
MAY PUT A REQUEST IN THE RIPPED
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE TO REVIEW
IT TO WAIVE EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE
OF THE ITEMS THAT MIGHT BE
INCLUDED IN AN ORDER TO REQUEST
READ THE ACTIONS AND IT'LL
BE UP AGAIN TO WILLIAM BARR AND
HIS TEAM TO MAKE THOSE
REDUCTIONS OR TO DECIDE IF THE
REDACTIONS WILL BE READ TO
CONGRESS AND THE PUBLIC.
IT'S ALSO POSSIBLE BECAUSE DON'T
FORGET THAT THIS IS ALL WITHIN
THE SAME BRANCH OF GOVERNMENT.
THE OFFICE OF THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL IS APPOINTED BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE, WHICH IS
PART OF THE ADMINISTRATION.
SO THIS IS ALL UNDER
ARTICLE 2 OF THE CONSTITUTION.
IT WOULD BE UNDER THE
PRESIDENT'S PURVIEW AND HIS
AUTHORIZATION TO REQUEST TO SEE
THE REPORT BEFORE IT GOES TO
CONGRESS.
I'M TOLD THAT'S THE LEAST LIKELY
SCENARIO.
FOR NOW, THIS IS IN THE HANDS OF
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL AND WE'LL
SEE WHAT WILLIAM BARR DECIDES TO
DO WITH IT.
THE PRESIDENT SAID THIS MORNING
THAT HE HAS FULL FAITH IN THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL AND THAT HE
BELIEVES HE WILL MAKE THE RIGHT
DECISION ON WHAT TO DO NEXT.
JUAN?
>> Juan: JOHN ROBERTS AT THE
WHITE HOUSE.
JOHN, THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
TO RECAP THOSE OF YOU JUST
JOINING COME OF ROBERT MUELLER
THE BOARD
REPORT HAS BEEN SUBMITTED TO
THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
WE ARE JOINED BY
CATHERINE HERRIDGE IN OUR
WASHINGTON BUREAU.
>> I'M GOING TO HEAD DOWN TO THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT, BUT WE'VE
GOT SOME INFORMATION, THE
TICK-TOCK OF EVENTS OVER THE
LAST HOUR.
WE HAVE CONFIRMED A LETTER WAS
SENT TO THE CHAIRMAN AND RANKING
MEMBERS OF THE SENATE AND HOUSE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE'S NOTIFYING
THEM TO THE SPECIAL COUNSEL
ROBERT MUELLER INVESTIGATION WAS
COMPLETED.
LET ME JUST READ FROM THAT TEXT,
SAYS "SPECIAL COUNSEL ROBERT
MUELLER THE THIRD HAS CONCLUDED
IN THE INVESTIGATION OF RUSSIAN
INTERFERENCE.
DELMA."
ATTORNEY GENERAL WILLIAM BARR
SAYS, "HE MAY BE IN A POSITION
TO ADVISE YOU, THE COMMITTEE, OF
THE SPECIAL COUNSEL'S PRINTABLE
CONCLUSIONS AS SOON THIS
WEEKEND."
THIS IS THE FIRST TIME THAT
WE'VE INDICATION THAT THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL MAY BE ABLE TO
MOVE VERY QUICKLY IN TERMS OF
RELEASING SOME INFORMATION AND
THE FINDINGS TO CONGRESS WITH
WHAT WE'VE SEEN IN THE LETTERS
SO FAR A TIMETABLE FOR A PUBLIC
RELEASE.
THIS WILL PROCESS THEY'LL MAKE
THIS WHOLE PROCESS WILL BE
GOVERNED BY SOMETHING CALLED
2600 CFR, IT'S VERY EXPLICIT
THAT THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
RECEIVES A CONFIDENTIAL REPORT
AND THERE HAS TO BE
NOTIFICATIONS TO CONGRESS OF THE
FINDINGS, IT'S A LITTLE MORE
VAGUE, ON WHETHER THAT'S A
SUMMARY FROM THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL OR HE CAN
INCLUDE SOME OF THE RAW DATA, IF
YOU WILL COME UP FROM THE
MUELLER REPORT.
THE OTHER THING THAT'S OFTEN
NEGLECTED IN THIS DISCUSSION
WHICH IS STIPULATED IN THE
REGULATIONS IS THAT THERE IS A
REQUIREMENT BY THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT TO NOTIFY CONGRESS OF
ANY ACTIONS THAT SPECIAL COUNSEL
ROBERT MUELLER WANTED TO TAKE
BUT WAS BLOCKED FROM TAKING BY
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL OR IN THE
ACTING ATTORNEY GENERAL.
THAT'S THE OTHER THING TO REALLY
WATCH.
AGAIN, TO RECAP, THINGS HAVE
MOVED VERY QUICKLY IN THE LAST
HOUR.
MY CONTACT SAID THEY WERE
NOTIFIED OF A SHORT NOTICE
MEETING ON CAPITOL HILL,
REPUBLICANS AND DEMOCRATS, ON
THE HOUSE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE,
THAT IT WOULD INVOLVE THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT, AND THAT WE
HAVE CONFIRMATION OF A LETTER TO
THE RANKING MEMBERS AND CHAIRMAN
OF THOSE COMMITTEES THAT THE
MUELLER REPORT IS NOW COMPLETE,
JUAN.
>> Emily: I HAVE A QUESTION.
IT MIGHT BE A TIMING THING.
WHEN YOU SAID THAT THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL SAID AS SOON AS
THIS WEEKEND REALLY SOMETHING, A
COUPLE OF WEEKS AGO THERE WERE
RUMORS THAT THIS REPORT HAD BEEN
DELIVERED TO THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL.
DO YOU THINK IT IS POSSIBLE THAT
THAT IS TRUE, THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL HAS HAD THIS
REPORT AND THAT IS WHY THEY ARE
MAKING THIS IS NOT
BEEN LATE ON A FRIDAY NIGHT AND
THEY THINK THEY CAN TURN ON
SOMETHING AND HE WAS JUST
RECEIVING IT THAT HE COULD TURN
SOMETHING AROUND THAT QUICKLY BY
SUNDAY?
>> Dana: IF YOU LOOK AT THE
REGULATIONS, IT'S VERY SPECIFIC
ABOUT WHAT HAS TO BE PROVIDED TO
CONGRESS.
IT HAS TO PROVIDE A CATALOG AND,
IF YOU WILL OF THE PROSECUTIONS
THAT WERE BROUGHT AND ALSO WHAT
THEY CALLED DECLINATIONS.
THESE ARE DECISIONS NOT TO
PROCEED WITH CRIMINAL
PROSECUTIONS BECAUSE THEY FEEL
LIKE THEY DON'T HAVE SUFFICIENT
EVIDENCE TO DO SO.
THAT IS NOT A LENGTHY DOCUMENT
THAT GOES INTO THE UNDERLYING
EVIDENCE.
THE REASON I MENTION THAT IT IS
THE DEPUTY ATTORNEY GENERAL ROD
ROSENSTEIN WAS VERY CLEAR IN A
LETTER TO SENATOR GRASSLEY, THE
FORMER HEAD OF THE SENATE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE, WHEN HE
SAID IN EFFECT THAT HE DIDN'T
WANT TO REPEAT THE SAME MISTAKES
THAT WERE MADE IN 2016, THAT
IT'S NOT THE DEPARTMENT'S
POSITION TO RELEASE INFORMATION
THAT IS DAMAGING TO INDIVIDUALS
WHO ARE NEVER PROSECUTED FOR ANY
CRIMES IN THE FUTURE.
THAT WAS IN REFERENCE, AND IT'S
CITED IN THE LETTER, TO THE
FORMER FBI DIRECTOR JAMES COMEY
AND HIS DECISION TO PUBLICLY
DISCUSS THE FINDINGS IN THE
CLINTON EMAIL CASE, BUT TO
RECOMMEND AGAINST CRIMINAL
PROSECUTIONS.
SO THE LONG ACTION, TO YOUR
CONCISE QUESTION, IS THAT WHEN
YOU LOOK AT THE REGULATIONS,
IT'S ENTIRELY POSSIBLE TO
DELIVER BARE BONES OF WHAT'S
REQUIRED IN A VERY SHORT
TIME FRAME.
THE UNKNOWN AND ALL OF THIS IS
WHETHER THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
WILLIAM BARR WILL IN FACT GO
FURTHER BECAUSE HE HAS SOME
DISCRETION TO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION AND THAT DO SO AND T
INFORMATION AND THAT DO SO AND E
INFORMATION AND THAT DO SO AND L
INFORMATION AND THAT DO SO AND Y
INFORMATION AND THAT DO SO AND W
INFORMATION AND THAT DO SO AND S
INFORMATION AND THAT DO SO AND A
INFORMATION AND THAT DO SO AND T
THE HEART, IF YOU WILL, OR THE
MAIN ELEMENT OF HIS TESTIMONY